was born in damascus in january 1941.
he was a close confidant of former
syrian leader hafez al-assad and then
his son
bashar al-assad a career diplomat his
tenure at the foreign service saw him
serving in saudi arabia
tanzania spain and the uk he was the
syrian ambassador to the u.s
between 1990 and 2000. on his return he
became assistant foreign minister
five years later he became deputy
foreign minister
he gave his first interview to a western
outlet in 2012 at the height of the
syrian war
accusing the u.s of creating terrorism
in his country
a vocal defender of the assad government
he often blamed others for the country's
problems
he denied the existence of the shibiha a
pro-government paid militia who were
suspected of committing atrocities
early on during the civil war while
blaming 60
of the violence on turkey qatar and
saudi arabia
with the united states as he called it
exercising its influence over all
others he was also present at many of
the talks aimed at ending the violence
over the years
but would often take a hard-line stance
calling opposition groups
terrorists throughout his tenure he
maintained close contacts with iran
meeting regularly with the leaders of
that country wallam would also hit out
at israel
at the united nations general assembly
in 2017 he accused it of supporting what
he called terror gangs
fighting against syrian interests the
speech also referenced the occupied
golan heights and his government's
desire to retake the territory
and in 2014 he had this exchange with
then u.n secretary general ban ki-moon
mr deputy prime minister i'm sorry to
just
you live in new york i live in syria
i have the right to give the syrian
virgin
here in this forum in recent years the
syrian government has relied on russia
to push its case to the international
community and turn the war in its favor
and throughout muam remained at the
center of the syrian government's
mission
you